yeah I'm still gonna break out the green
screen for Doctor Who
quick reminder I do not just for the
Freddie Moore that is your spoiler
warning here we go the return of doctor
Mysterio the latest Christmas special
for Doctor Who and I'll just kind of
jump to the end I like it I like it a
lot now I can see where some fans of
Doctor Who will not like it it kind of
depends on how strong the sort of cross
section is for you your love of comic
book superhero comic books and your love
of Doctor Who and whether you're okay
with those to marry in my case I love
superheroes I love superhero comic books
I love a good superhero movies I love
Doctor Who I am happy to see the two
married but I have a feeling that this
is gonna strain some Doctor Who fans I I
don't want to call it a little
suspension of disbelief but there are
some elements of Doctor Who that and
first of all let's be clear have been
there from the beginning this is not a
muffin ruining Doctor Who I mean the
second doctor has had a story where he
was trapped in the land of fiction so
this is not new stuff but anyway the
whole section of Doctor Who fandom who
don't like those sort of more fairy tale
more outlandish aspects even if they
find a way to kind of justify it within
the world of Doctor Who but me I've
never had that problem I like the more
whimsical episodes by and large I mean
they can still go off the rails this one
does not I think this is a terrific
marriage of a very Golden Age feeling
for superheroes and if you know your
comic books I'm talking about like
classic Superman I'm talking forties
like 60s at the most current so this is
classic take on Superman right down to
the glasses and I think it's terrific
I think Justin Chadwick is he's a guy
who he's been stuck in the lousy movies
right he's actually kind of still been
paying career-wise for the fact that he
starred in Dragonball Evolution and I
mean he wasn't good at that but
when he was but he's got a good presence
and he's a good fit for this kind of
part I didn't look up the actresses name
when I feel bad now but the girl please
Lucy I like her a lot - I like how smart
she is how whip-smart she is and I like
I'm I even like the squeezy toy as
ridiculous as that was I thought that
was great but I liked how quickly
jealous was like Sherlock Holmes Ian
with how quickly she picks something up
and then explain why she figured that
out it was just really cool to see I
liked well-written smart characters
where they're not just know-it-alls and
we get to see the process by which we
understand they are smart surprised I
think they liked Matt Lucas as Naruto I
thought he was terrific almost the whole
time I will grant his opening joke just
landed with a thud but he bounced back
from that very quickly and I loved his
rapport with Capaldi I liked the feel
that he brings this sort of I love that
he's sort of don't be in an odd but I
can't I don't think he's stupid he's
just way out of his depth but at the
same time he's got the doctor's number
and that's a that's a funny mix to do
and I really like it then I didn't like
it Thursday and when he was panicking he
was getting choked he was just screaming
that I couldn't done without but aside
from those two moments almost everything
he did or said was gold I loved it I
liked that he I liked that he came back
I like that he's sticking around he's in
fact so good that I found myself
wondering do we need to add another
companion to this but again I'll try not
to be judgmental on a character who we
haven't even met yet but okay well we'll
get off that cake so a big relief for me
Peter Capaldi as a doctor it's all I
hated no capacity was good as the doctor
of course he's good as the doctor but
what I was really afraid of was that
coming off of the previous series was
that he was going to basically revert
back to his first series now I liked
compiled these second series way better
than his first series and Wes I'm
talking specifically in terms of his
characterization and
I just liked how loser he got how much
more fun he was having he was very
serious that first series and it worked
it wasn't bad but I love the transition
and some of the things like it said as
the new series was being filmed they you
know said things that made me wonder Oh
are they gonna go back and then they put
him very solidly back in that that that
series eight costume and I have liked
the more casual you know occasion he had
a hoodie and you know I I liked the
sonic sunglasses so when those elements
were being taken away and they had all
added to the sort of aging rock star
field that I really liked about the
doctor in series 9 I was worried I was
gonna lose that feel but it's not gone
it's there I mean I love I love that
he's right next to Lucy I don't worry
I'm an intruder too and he's just
snacking on sushi then he knows to bring
bring snacks it's ah it was so good and
he was so fun I love these kinds of
stories where the doctor does save the
day but not alone he's not the sole one
manipulating everything I think the
world would have been lost without him
but the world also would have been lost
without grant has the go so I I like
that balance as well when they get it
right and I think this one gets it right
really well I suppose that there's a
weak element in it the the villains are
kind of generic I mean the idea the
brains coming in that's it's an okay
idea I don't know if that little
cliffhanger at the end you know it's
like oh this guy I don't know if that'll
actually be a thing or not I'd be open
to it we'll see and the surgeons were
generic as heck I mean doctor who can
make the sort of faceless minion thing
work really well I mean obviously you
know the empty child was amazing but
this surgeons they're just like okay
whatever but that said their scheme and
what they were playing to do was up
pretty good I mean the doctor himself
said that's a really good plan and it
was a pretty cool plan but you know look
if there's a
week's point to this it's the villains
but the villains also aren't the point
and this is very much about the hero
about the ghosts and about the doctors
connection with him and and all of that
stuff so the stuff that matters the
reason that the story is being told is
all excellent and I really really really
enjoyed this episode again I get why
some people mind might not and if you
like sci-fi but more fantasy elements
cuz I mean I think by and large
superheroes fall more in line with
fantasy really there's lots of things
that go on so if you're reading the
superhero comics as opposed to watching
movies there's lots of things that
happen just because and that's fantasy
approach to storytelling as opposed to
sci-fi and if that's not your bag this
may rub you the wrong way a little bit
for me though this this hit had a huge
grin on my face had an absolute blast
now there was also the little bonus
thing the little sort of teaser for
series 10 and I'm not gonna talk about
that here I'm gonna do that in a
separate video but I'll give my thoughts
on that as well so Lourdes heard of
doctor Mysterio have you seen it what
did you think about it whatever you
thought drop something down in the
comments and let's talk about it don't
forget to like subscribe to our
notifications so you know when I've got
new videos up check me out on Twitter at
council of geeks give a listen to the
council of geeks podcast available on
iTunes and stitcher and until next time
this council is adjourned